bonjour je vous invite dans le cher où
le val de germiny a vu son paysage rural
se transformer avec l'arrivée de
l'industrie qui dit produire 10
transporter que ce soit des matières
premières ou que ce soit des produits
finis alors devant les aléas du noir
indomptables difficile les hommes ont
décidé de construire des canaux
nous partons pour le val de germiny aval
rural dont le sous-sol riche en minerais
et argile participe à la transformation
du paysage car dès le 14e siècle
desforges s'installe l'activité de la
comté pu faire domineront des activités
duval pendant les 18 et 19ème siècle
c'est par voie d'eau la loire et
l'allier qui sont acheminés coque
charbon combustible nécessaire aux
forges les deux fleuves ne sont pas
aisément navigables empêchant la
régularité de la production début xixème
siècle sont alors construit le canal
latéral à la loire et le canal de berry
le premier reliant le val au territoire
national et le second les industries du
bal
c'est ici à marseille les aubigny que
les deux canaux se rejoignent yvan
connais bien l'histoire du val
élocution n'a vraiment une lieu
stratégique d'un point de vue économique
un noeud des changes à qui fonctionne un
petit peu comme une gare de triage on
est sûr on est ni
plus ni moins dans une gare de triage où
on pouvait transbordés matjan à canal à
un autre avec les canaux l'essor
industriel de la vallée sans précédent à
la sidérurgie viennent s'ajouter des
industries de la tuile de la brique de
la chaux et du ciment a quand même un
mouvement de va-et-vient comme sa
perpétuelle entre la et l'autre où le
canal est là pour servir les industries
préexistantes mais la présence du canal
va y contribuer largement développement
de ses industries vers 1930 le fret
fluvial et 2 2 millions de tonnes
la région prospère forgeant sur moins de
40 km un étonnant paysage rural rennais
de canaux du sinn des cluses et de ponts
dont le plus remarquable est le
pont-canal budget à
surplombant l'allier long de 350 m il
fut construit de 1832 à 1835
sa construction est le maillon qui
permet au canal latéral à la loire de
rejoindre le réseau national des canaux
canal latéral à la loi par de digoin et
verisk à briare dont il fait partie du
réseau de canaux qui ont été voulues par
l'état français de façon à rallier la
mer méditerranée à la mer du nord en
passant par le rhône la saône le canal
du chantre de canal latéral canal de
briare puis d'assen
et
il faut imaginer un trafic est très
intense puisque on en est arrivé à
écluser même la nuit le pont canal a été
à une période équipé de becs de gaz pour
que l'activité soit en permanence pour
pouvoir écouler ce flot de bateau comme
ça qui allait dans les deux sens
au pied du pont canal un petit village
du fille née des besoins liés à
l'activité fluviale
le hameau qui se trouve à côté du pont
canal est née de la construction du pont
canal s'il fallait pouvoir répondre à
toute cette activité il fallait offrir
des services notamment des services à
destination des chevaux il fallait
pouvoir les ferrer il fallait les
nourrir il fallait nourrir également les
mariniers fallait pouvoir s'équiper donc
il ya des magasin d'accastillage on
pouvait se rééquiper en cordage en
perche de bois etc fin 19ème siècle
l'espoir mis dans les canaux ne se
vérifie pas pour l'industrie du fer car
le transport de la houille est trop
coûteux les sidérurgistes iront alors
s'installer près des houillères dans le
nord de la france la sidérurgie s'éteint
doucement la crise économique des années
30 puis la deuxième guerre mondiale
mettront un coup d'arrêt quasi définitif
à l'industrie duval le canal du berry
pâti de cette baisse d'activité
déclassé dans les années 50 il
disparaîtra du paysage c'est assez
surprenant de voir à quelle vitesse ce
patrimoine industriel et et rayer de la
carte un patrimoine toujours changeant
comme avec l'arrivée du chemin de fer
concurrents des canaux en france entre
1850 et 1880 23 mille kilomètres de
voies sont ouvertes régulier rapide le
train vient jusqu'à s'installer sur les
berges et chemins de halage des canaux
modifiant le paysage déjà fortement
marquée par le développement de la
grande industrie aujourd'hui le val
d'oise trouvé son avenir entre industrie
activités rurales et patrimoine
il faut effectivement trouver un
compromis entre la mise en valeur d'un
patrimoine
avec tout un volet historique qu'est mal
connues méconnues et qu'il faut mettre
en lumière et qu'il faut mieux faire
connaître mais c'est important de
continuer de pas sanctuariser et d'avoir
une activité qui persiste parce que
effectivement on quand on pense à
d'autres régions une fois que tout est
et a donc apprendre et dans une autre
démarche on va faire de la collecte on
va faire du on a cherché les témoignages
et aujourd'hui on en est on est à la
croisée de ces chemins entre le
témoignage passé l'activité qui est
encore bien réel donc c'est important
que tout ça cohabitent l'avenir du val
et sans doute dans ce compromis ou le
passé se doit d'être toujours perméable
aux paysages à venir